[Music]
[Music]
good morning I've been given the honor
of introducing our speaker my name is
simone schoener
and i'm a PhD candidate in the
Department of Economics earlier this
morning several of us students were
privileged to show mr. gates examples of
our research mine focuses on the use of
malaria diagnostic tests in
antimalarials among low income
households in Africa public health
issues such as malaria are among the
many problems tackled by the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation in a quest to
help all people lead healthy and
productive lives at MIT we share the
foundation's ambition to confront big
problems with big solutions as we pursue
our mission to serve the nation in the
world
mr. Gates has long been a friend to the
Institute and his work toward the
betterment of humankind continues to
inspire us we are honored that he has
chosen to visit us as part of his
college tour please welcome Bill Gates
thank you
well it's great to be here when I
dropped out of college I promised my dad
I'd go back and so I'm doing it kind of
a day at a time to work off that that
debt that I've got there's the first
college a set of visits I've done since
switching to work full-time for the
Gates Foundation and it's a little bit
different than the kind of talks I gave
when I was coming out focused on
software focused on Microsoft I'll talk
a bit about technology and how it's an
enabling factor but mostly I want to
talk about a question that fascinates me
and that's his are the brightest minds
working on the most important problems
and to the degree that they're not how
could we increase that which I think
would make a huge difference now this is
a question that you know we'd like to be
as precise as possible but I think it'll
be tough to be too numeric on it after
all if we think about what do we mean by
the brightest minds now you could have a
range of definitions of that but I think
any definition would include the people
who get to attend the world's top 20
universities and so everyone here would
would fit into that category also if we
take a phrase like important problems I
think there would be different lists
that people would come up with I think
there's some things that would be in
common the problems in poor countries
the health problems sanitation problems
governance problems in ability to do
savings get loans all of those problems
that make life so much more difficult
for the bottom two billion versus us
particularly the the richest 1 billion
would belong on that list and there
would be five or six really big things
that we haven't put enough attention
into that would make a huge difference
we'd also have in the list some problems
that are more global in nature you know
for example the problem of Education
it's not something that even the world's
richest country the United States has
managed to improve and make equitable
and make available to everybody who
should want it or we'd have the problem
of energy
we're getting energy to be lower and
lower cost is very important for
everybody and now we have a new
constraint that we have to do that in a
way that eliminates the environmental
negative effects including that co2
emission you might have on the list the
difficulty of feeding the world where
you don't have much more acreage you can
put under cultivation and yet both the
population increase factor 1.5 and the
dietary change you get is people get
rich or mean that we're gonna have to
have about three times the agricultural
output and the only trick that we have
for that is increased productivity and
so a huge challenge also on with
significant environmental constraints so
those are the kinds of things I think
about when I think about the important
problems and for many of these problems
the amount of work that's been done on
very central questions
it always stuns me how few bright minds
have worked on those things how little
effort and energy and investigation
there is on those things and it makes me
wonder how we might change that how we
might make these things more exciting I
was thinking about this about three
weeks ago I was with some friends just
goofing around on the weekend and they
had a couple topics that their
incredible minds had really focused on
and you know we're thinking in this rich
deep way where they knew the history
they knew the strategies they know the
outputs the two topics were first NCAA
March Madness and what was going to
happen in basketball I don't remember
anyone mentioning the MIT teams in those
discussions but
that's okay and you know they really had
studied these problems you know they had
those brackets and they were talking
about which was gonna be best and a
wonderful debate about those topics and
the second thing was discussing of
investments you know who would pick good
stocks what had happened in the mortgage
market what was gonna happen that the
investment things what kind of
derivatives were there and did various
people understand what what you might
choose to do in investing in those
things and in all that IQ including you
know lots of IQ that goes off to Wall
Street and just works on that on those
those topics is their full-time thing so
we have lots of talent that could be
shifted at least to some degree from
sports entertainment investing even in
the areas of innovation that kind of
great science that's it's done here in
other places a lot of that focuses on
the needs of the rich you know there's a
lot of great work on baldness drugs now
you know I'm not talking about a
complete chip because I I still want to
have some movies I like movies and I
certainly know people that would be
easier to look at if they'd use to
baldness drug but you know how could we
have a shift of both people who work on
these issues on a full-time basis and
perhaps even more importantly people who
although it's not their full-time focus
that they're engaged in these things
they picked one or two and they're their
time their donation their political
voice is involved in these things I
think if you look at the trend over the
last
Oh 15 years or so there has been an
increase and places like MIT have been
very good in taking leadership on this
if you look at the visibility of issues
like malaria and AIDS it is much higher
today than any any time in the past and
that is resulting in more government
donations more
scientists working on those things still
have you take malaria it's a pretty
small set you know there's less than a
hundred scientists who work on the key
problems of malaria kills a million
children a year you know should it have
more than that
maybe so but so we've seen a change you
know my generation was not that aware of
poverty and what was going on I don't
know whether it was the Cold War or what
the distraction was but it was not as
visible not as as clear as it as it's
starting to be now I see the shift in in
many ways I see it in terms of what the
students here are going into I have a
project up in Seattle which is about
using software to model diseases and an
MIT graduate crema nog Lima is working
on that and you know she could make 10
times as much money working on something
else but this idea of modeling malaria
and other diseases and testing out the
tactics and using actually this Monte
Carlo simulation which is a technique
from physics implying it to that in this
very rich way you know that problem has
has drawn her in and we've got this team
of amazing people doing doing that we
have some exemplars people like Paul
Farmer who people aspire to do the kind
of work that he does and it's not just
the global issues also on education and
Teach for America is a new phenomena
here at MIT there were 96 people in the
graduating class who applied for Teach
for America and that's seven-and-a-half
percent of the class and that's pretty
amazing because every one of those kids
would have had other opportunities that
would have been far more renew Murrah
t'v so there is this increased
visibility I myself did not go through
some rational process of picking what I
wanted to work on based on either
economics or it ranking high and some
lists I wrote down of great problems I
fell into what I ended up doing is my
full
time career-highs 13 there was a
computer it confused the teachers it was
fun to figure it out and that became my
fanatical involvement was thinking how
could software improve how could it be
better trying to meet people who were
good at had done more you know getting
them to critique what I had done and
then eventually starting a company
around that idea and I feel good that
you can say through happenstance that
work actually led to a broad industry
personal computing internet software
that has been incredibly empowering it
had has had both in a direct sense but
also as a tool to be used for these
other problems it has been fantastic and
so I don't look back on that with any
regret it well it did work out but I
didn't know what was going on in the
world I was in my 40s before in terms of
my travels I started really having an
awareness of how tough health conditions
were and I remember in particular
reading an article about disease in poor
countries and seeing there was a disease
I'd never heard of called rotavirus that
was killing a million kids happening
kids a year and thinking well boy there
must be a lot of scientists working on
that well in fact at that time there
about ten scientists working on that you
know not well funded and you know just
an obvious thing and so I thought wow
the world is not that rational it is not
sort of sort of these things and in a
way that was good news for me personally
it meant there were some very clear
things that as I was taking the
Microsoft resources and giving them back
to society and trying to have impact
there were some low-hanging fruit that
hadn't been picked I wasn't gonna be you
know if the world was was rational my
marginal dollars would have far less
utility than if there was these things
that really had been missed what I
wanted to is take two problems including
that one of childhood deaths and talk
about what's going on and some of the
things that need more bright minds and
you know give me my sense a sense of the
very deep need on many of these and yet
the great opportunity
the chance of success I think if you
took and tried to give the world a
report card one of the things you'd have
very strongly even you know if you only
pick ten managers would be the number of
childhood deaths some of you know
there's an effort now that we funded
called the Millennium Development Goals
that are trying to benchmark where
different countries are in the progress
and set fairly ambitious goals for
improving metrics and one of those is
this under five child to death number
and they're the milestone for those
goals is 2015 and we'll make pretty good
progress we want to achieve them all but
it has had a very positive effect so
this is a very interesting metric and I
actually have one chart I'm only going
to show you one but it's it's my
favorite chart in the world and that's
one that shows the progress over time in
reducing these childhood deaths if you
go back to 1960 over 20 million children
died that year if you come up to the
last year which was the the most recent
measurement we have on this it was under
9 million children and there's about a
40% increase in the size of the birth
cohort so the actual rate reduction of
God is actually even better than the
factor of 2 you see her in the absolute
number and so you might say how did that
happen what is it you know is it cancer
drugs is that you know what kind of
science did it and the answer is
although some of it is just nutrition
and income levels the general advance of
GDP per person and the the living
conditions you're under by far most of
that is vaccines measles vaccine alone
is over a million of that reduction
smallpox vaccine that led actually to
the first eradication of a disease
altogether is a huge part of this
reduction well over a million death
reduction per year because of that and
so vaccines which get less than 1% of
the focus on medical spending goes into
that area they or respond
for a really incredible amount of health
benefit even in even in rich countries
it's a a under appreciated element of
why things work and you know they're
very cheap the manufacturing cost comes
down over time to most a few dollars you
can deliver them as a group
you don't need trained medical personnel
to do it and even in a country like
Somalia where you essentially have no
government we have quite high
vaccination rates actually much better
than we have in northern Nigeria in
northern India where you have a
dysfunctional vaccination system that's
only getting to 30 percent in some of
those areas so it's a huge problem we
have to fix while at the same time we
add in in these new vaccines when you
think about the inequities of the
childhood deaths I you know I always
think about where how's the way you can
state that that is the most clear one
that I think is interesting is to say
other people who were born the same year
you were your birth cohort how old were
you before twenty percent of you had
died and in a rich country in the United
States
you'd get past age 60 before 20 percent
had died in a poor country the poorest
you wouldn't get past age four before 20
percent had died so you know very
dramatic difference the thing that was
kind of mind-blowing we found out about
this is the effect that improved health
haves on population growth the first
thing our foundation did actually was
invest in reproductive health because we
said okay well whatever the problems
you're interested in not having too many
more people whether it's jobs education
food environment to not have sort of
Malthusian growth levels like three four
five percent a year which we fortunately
only have in a few places now that is a
primary problem and I wasn't sure what
how to think about health interventions
because you know are you schizophrenic
do you want more people
less people and wouldn't that be the
first-class effect well the answer is no
paradoxically the biggest intervention
that reduces the family size that people
want to have is improving childhood
health there's some others like female
literacy and things that can be done
Hans Rosen who's from Karolinska has a
presentation on the web a TED
presentation number of others where he
really articulates there's only two
kinds of countries there's high
population growth countries with
terrible health and there's low
population growth countries with
reasonable health and there's no no
in-between because this effect is so
powerful that as you improve childhood
health parents were trying to have a few
kids surviving to adulthood choose not
to have as large a family size so what
you get is as soon as you start to
improve health all these other things
become tractable and you have many
countries that we used to think of as
poor and received aid even South Korea
30 years ago got aid now it's a quite a
generous aid donor so it's a complete
turnaround from recipient to giving
within a 40 year period but you know
it's true of China Brazil lots of
countries so now we're down to what Paul
Collier calls the bottom billion maybe
billion and a half or so that are in
this poverty trap that we still need to
better on and the good news is that
despite the complexities of and
difficulties of these things something
like vaccinations can be delivered
anywhere so inventing knows getting to
be cheap getting them out getting a
slightly better distribution system will
allow us to go from that slightly under
nine million that we're at today down to
five million down to two and a half
million and it has this huge huge effect
the other problem I want to take this an
illustrative example is education and
[Music]
education you know economists of all the
things that's known for sure investing
in education primary second
very college-level doing that in quality
way is the thing that really allows a
country to improve its standard of
living so both of that kind of macro
level but also at the individual level
you know we all know from our personal
experience that education what is what
makes our life interesting gives us
opportunity and so we should want it to
be broadly available if you look and I
was absolutely blown away at the
statistics I had no idea of how poorly
the education system in the u.s. is
working over 30% of kids drop out of
high school if you're a minority over
50% drop out of high school even the
ones who complete many of them have had
a really really poor education and so
they they sign up for college they get
into a remedial math class and a half of
those kids never get any degree so
they've got loans they're paying off
they've got this negative experience
they put time into it and it hasn't
worked for them at all and so this
education system is quite porn it's it's
kind of been covered up hasn't been that
visible what we have now is a trend that
because of the way state budgets are
allocated a great education is going to
be more and more out of reach that is
the tuitions more expensive and so we
literally will have a situation where
less people are getting college
education unless we do something fairly
dramatic to improve the efficiency make
some some type of breakthrough so I'd
say there's two things that are two that
are very important one is to take the
quality of teaching and this is
particularly in K through 12 and find
out what the best practices are and how
to spread those best practices and it
blows my mind how little work has been
done on that to identify now that we
know some teachers are wildly better
than most teachers you make over two
years of progress in math if you get a
top quartile teacher and you make zero
years of progress if you get a bottom
quartile teacher so what's going on you
know is it seniority we know it's not is
it having a PhD in math
we know it's not that either that has a
very little effect on it and although
people have focused on it there's huge
differences of how the kids are being
drawn in and yet you know we don't study
that we don't invest in spreading it
around we don't measure teachers give
them feedback it's a system there's a
huge opportunity to improve so that's
important and the other thing I think is
is using technology and here's a case
where mi t--'s absolutely been at the
forefront OpenCourseWare you know
there's great numbers in terms of how
much it's being used by millions of
people I'm a super happy user you know I
retook physics with Walter Lewin I took
professor Sadoway course and love that I
I recommend it to everybody you know
Eric Lander biology you know refresher
on differential equations actually the
33 that they have videos I've taken 11
and I just last night spotted two new
ones that I need to take so just for me
it's a good thing but this is just the
beginning you know and and you know it's
MIT did spark a lot of people to do
similar things but the percentage of
people using these things and the
difficulty of finding something and in
testing your knowledge really bringing
the best of video the best professors in
the world have interactive experiments
interactive ways of testing your
knowledge even accreditation have a way
that if you have gathered this knowledge
instead of that all coming bundled with
the degree where you had to be somewhere
for four years you know fairly expensive
say quarter-million actually have the
accreditation piece be separated out so
you can have innovation in terms of how
people acquire the knowledge and and
separate it from place-based learning
now the exact amount that this is is not
clear you know there's some schools like
rocketship who even at the middle school
level are using online courses and
mixing that in with live teaching it's
an area that needs be tried and you know
you have to keep the kids motivated you
have to help when they get get confused
some of that will be faced
but there's online innovation there too
right now
it's all pretty fragmented you know
different universities doing different
courses it's kind of hard to find things
academic growth does a little bit of
aggregation there but this can improve
very substantially I was talking with
victor zue about how we take speech
recognition and and bring that in and we
were talking about making it more
modular if you just want to learn
different concepts so we are just
scratching the surface and the need to
take this and have teachers be able to
learn how to teach better to assign kids
or ahead to assign kids who are behind
or to have self-motivated people go in
and use this and and have it be a
worldwide resource that's very clear who
should use what that's something that
needs get done and you know that again
it's what's been done so far has had
very modest funding this is an area we
need more resources more bright minds
and certainly one that I want to see how
the foundation can make a contribution
to this so if you look at the two issues
childhood deaths education or if you
look at the other ones savings where the
cellphone can bring down the transaction
costs sanitation or advanced physics and
chemistry really can do that in a
different way energy and maybe the
toughest one of all but again one where
MIT is marshalling its resources to make
a stronger contribution as it can these
important problems there's reasons to
believe we can make progress but that
rida progress will be somewhat
proportional to how we draw people in
draw them in full-time draw them in
part-time on on these issues so it does
leave this almost meta question of how
to get the brightest people more on to
these big problems what why don't they
work on them well the economic rewards
aren't totally in line with these
problems you know that's interesting we
can think about what would change that
the visibility getting the success
stories out how
how can we do that my dream is that you
know say a few years from now I'll go
off and I'll have a weekend and instead
of talking about in March Madness and
stock prices and we'll have these
brackets about the best teaching and
which ideas have been tried teen
teaching online and we'll be comparing
which had really come out with the best
outcomes and then we'll we'll talk about
food and you know the best seeds the new
agricultural practices that are
increasing this productivity and you
know we'll have that same kind of
excitement and understanding that we
have about other topics I don't think
that specifically is going to be easy to
achieve but you know it's kind of a high
bar of why aren't these topics as
interesting is engaging as those other
things and if we really did that yes and
we might delayed in the invention of a
new financial product by a few years we
might even delay that step baldness
drugs by a few years but if it helps on
the important problems I think it's a
good thing thank you
great will are the rest of time is for
QA I think the way it's set up there's
the two mics there's one here and one
there and just go to the mics and ask a
question I mean just say your name and
what area you're studying in that give
me a little bit of context that'd be
great
so I go ahead here why can't I actually
hear to ask the same question my name is
Grace Chen and I'm a member of a student
initiative here at MIT called leaders in
global health transformations or lights
and we're composed of undergraduate
students graduates and business students
from across campus now as the world's
foremost supporter of technological
solutions to global health you know
better than anyone that in order to
produce a new technology that has a
large global impact not only is there a
need for inventive scientists and
engineers to build the technology but
also a need for great entrepreneurs to
disseminate the technology and build
value a need for people who understand
delivery and operations on the ground
and a need for rigorous evaluation and
systems analysis here at MIT we have the
world's best minds in all of these areas
and many of these experts are currently
engaging in various projects in global
health results of a survey really
recently distributed through the Provost
office review revealed that over 40 MIT
faculty are engaged in some global
health research and 17 student groups
have an interest in this area however
these efforts are currently very
isolated with little collaboration
between the different sectors we believe
that if these efforts are better
coordinated MIT is as whole would be
very well positioned to play an
important role in solving health
problems in global health
so our questions to you a threefold
first would you be would you be
supportive of a centralized
administrative led initiative committed
to supporting global health at MIT much
like the initiative that already exists
more energy to how do you think this
initiative might be implemented
and three how would the Gates Foundation
be interested in partnering with such
initiative thank you well I definitely
applaud the work that's going on and I
do think MIT is is an exemplar of this
one of the things we're trying to get is
the institutions in the developing
countries particularly in Africa in
India more involved in this and transfer
some of the expertise and skills so that
you know they where the needs are
actually are a more capable of doing
some of the elements including policy
measurement things of that kind
the idea of how universities organize
you know it's not a deep expertise that
I have and so the question of whether
there should be a minor or some new
thing that pulls us together I I think
that's definitely worth looking at I'd
encourage you if you do it though to not
just take health by itself - I'd say you
know broaden it to International
Development because the issues of
Agriculture savings there's quite a few
issues and I'd say the awareness at MIT
of the health issues is ahead of some of
those other issues and yet the the kind
of expertise is equally applicable to
those things and once we improve health
we still want to work on those things
you know today what we've done with MIT
is we take particular projects like the
measurement and evaluation and we we
fund that the you know Bruce Walker does
a lot of the best work on aids and we
fund a lot of his activities whether a
particular thing should be done at a
single university level here or if
there's some other missing thing I'm not
sure I did see a few things today you
know like where people are doing medical
instruments where I said okay we should
make sure that the needs you know what
are they using what are the problems
what they're using what is the gap there
that we really do a survey so people are
picking the right thing so that's a
particular one but you know we'll have a
dialogue about whether a miner and
Institute makes sense and you know
whether that's value-added or or how
that can help Thanks hi my name is
Michael Kohlberg and I'm a postdoc in
the Cancer Center really I just want to
say thank you for coming to speak with
us today and I'm half of MIT and really
everyone in the world thank you for the
work you've done you do and will
continue to do thank you my name is
Alejandra menchaca I work on energy
efficiency in buildings and my question
has to do with population growth in my
field we try to reduce or at least where
I work we're trying to reduce demand an
order that we don't have to work too
hard on the supply side in terms of
population it's a hard issue to tell
people whether to have a certain number
of kids or not but clearly it is a
population growth is clearly a problem
in terms of supplying as you mentioned
earlier the food and the energy and
everything staying sustainable do you
think we will ever get to a point in
which population will be controlled and
a more I don't have legal way or
something like that or it's something
that will never be touch I know it's I
wouldn't like to be told you know you
can't have more than a certain number of
kids but at the same time it is a
problem so how do you see that issue
yeah the miracle here if you go back to
1970 the estimates were that world
population would reach about 20 billion
and that's because people didn't
understand this effect of how health
would would have an impact and so they
lowered it to 18 to 16 to 14 and now the
consensus is about nine point two
billion peak global population in about
2050 now for a glow on a global basis
you know that's probably okay and we
won't do much you know maybe we could
get it to be 8.5 or something the
problem is that that population growth
is exactly where we have the least
resources the least good government the
least infrastructure at least education
holy food capability and all of the
increase from the current 6.2 billion
that were at today to that around 9
billion plus or minus is going to come
in poor countries in urban cities that a
lot of the births will be in the rural
areas but net it's going to be in these
mega cities that are are somewhat
dysfunctional and so our reproductive
health program is able to substantially
lower birth rates because there's unmet
demand that is if you just go out to
women and tell them okay you know
there's a shot they can take that works
for 90 days or there's an implant that
works for three years you know we're
gonna be able to bring the price of
those supplies down very dramatically
and it's an area that was ridiculously
not funded in fact the US government
completely pulled out of the UN
Population group because of this issue
that some of these groups are involved
in voluntary abortion and so the u.s.
didn't didn't want to be connected in
any way even with that piece now that
rule of so-called Mexico City gag rule
was eliminated by President Obama so for
the first time the u.s. is back funding
some of the delivery activities but the
innovation here
there's a lot that can be done as you
bring the price of these things down the
injections the implants as you get the
word out the demand is there so it's all
completely voluntary
you know women want to have a smaller
family in all of these high population
growth areas and so there's no need to
worry about course of things in fact you
know back in the 60s they the Club of
Rome people who are these doom and gloom
people you know we're saying that we had
to have course of techniques and they
just didn't didn't understand so you
should have a very positive view of this
the people want out
smaller families the advances are coming
that will make that easier
it won't come soon enough in a way you
know take Cannes Annie it's a population
of 42 million now even with the modest
birthrate it'll get to 90 million
because they have the age structure such
you have all these young people that
when they go and have have their
children will about double the
population one of the ironies in
population is that the rich countries
are shrinking the u.s. is the only rich
country that has a population growth
Japan Italy Germany are shrinking Mexico
even if they're you know middle income
level is actually shrinking and yet you
think oh we should have more immigration
you know we should take all these young
people and keep our age structure
reasonable but you know politically
that's that's fairly difficult to do
even in India this is an amazing thing
in the south of India and Kerala there
below which is the part of India with
really good health care it's it's
substantially the best there actually
below replacement rate whereas in the
same country you go up to tar Pradesh
that's three and a half percent growth
year so one of the highest population
growth in the entire world the two
highest population growth areas are
actually northern Nigeria northern India
which is also where you don't have good
vaccination and so it's in a way it's
good news because you do the
interventions with the reproductive
health and the vaccines and the
childhood care all in these same places
and it's very focused where you go and
do that work my name's Alan Bryan I in
Health Sciences and technology I have a
PhD in bioinformatics I'm a medical
student and so I'm now gonna work in
medical informatics my question is
single but with two applications you
spoke of particularly of vaccines and of
improving education methods in both
there's there's a two-part problem one
is how to find what works better and the
second is how to get what works better
out to people who need it
in both cases which do you find harder
so for vaccines is it harder and this is
based on your past experience talking to
people
then there are their future projections
is it harder to to do the research to
find the vaccine or to establish the
cold chain that gets it out to people
and likewise in education reform is it
harder to figure out what best best
practices really are and that are
transferable and are not in a - you know
some organization or some teachers
personal patterns of action or something
or is it harder to talk through the
accreditation process and schools of
Education Department's of Education and
so forth to get it integrated into the
system yeah that's a very good question
and the answer is different for the two
different domains in the case of
vaccines we are science limited that is
an AIDS vaccine is very tricky you know
we're having to learn basic things about
molecular shape space immunology it is
interesting but it's taking us a lot
longer because we haven't gotten lucky
on on that one so that science limited
malaria vaccine it's criminal that we
didn't work on it because probably the
science of the 80s or 90s were good
enough to do a malaria vaccine they were
not good enough to know an AIDS vaccine
even if we'd been working super hard we
just didn't have the fundamental
understandings most the diseases we work
on the vaccines aren't that hard it's
just there wasn't money put into it and
so now it's it's moving at full speed
now and the delivery thing we're gonna
have to raise money billions but you're
talking about saving lives for less than
$2,000 invested that its funding
vaccination saves lives for less than
$2,000 and because in the u.s. we'll
spend you know 2 million or 20 million
to save a life then you say okay are
these lives really less than a thousand
times as valuable I mean maybe there are
400 this valuable but a thousand that's
getting kind of extreme I mean even in
the Constitution
you know slaves were worth what
three-fifths of a boat or something like
that so you know in terms of
discrimination numerically this is
pretty extreme stuff if you fail to fund
the vaccines which right now on the
budget
we're having a challenge with that but
in a long run we won't on cold-chain
there's this great science of these
super thermoses that should avoid us
having to use electrification which is
very tough because if it goes out the
vaccine spoils and electricity policies
in these countries are so bad that using
a solution that's sort of passive energy
to get the coal basically ice in a in a
superstore in a Dewar's type thing we
think we can replace cold chain but even
if we have to use refrigerators you know
we can do it you have to over by the
vaccines because of the fact that some
of them will will spoil so that one's
science limited the education one even
though we don't know it's mind-blowing
how little we know about what good
teachers do and how you would invest in
spreading that around I think that we'll
finally get some good work going on you
know the field needs about 50 times as
many people working on it we need the
schools of Education to show up and and
get serious about this we need some of
the methodologies of real measurement to
be applied to it the hardest thing there
even once we know what to do is going to
be convincing people to do it in fact we
have an existence proof Kip is a charter
school that there's 82 of these schools
that runs for less than the cost of
public schools and it's able to take
inner-city kids the poorest kids and get
over 95% of them to go to college and
get a four-year degree and it doesn't
take numbers if you walk into a Kipp
school you know you're in a very
different place
you know within 15 minutes of being in
there that is some amazing teaching
being done there and it's a different
personnel system it's a long school day
it's just very different than a public
school so the red here the limiting
factor absolutely is taking current
practice which is sort of a you know I'm
doing God's work don't measure me
seniority is is good stuff
type system that you know there are many
great practitioners in that system but
there's no real effort to
spread that we have five sites in the US
that we've given 400 million to where
the Union and the District signed up to
have teacher measurements so we put
webcams in so you can you know see the
video you don't have people walking into
the classroom that's very disruptive we
do teep student surveys we do pair of
surveys we look at the test data coming
in and going out a variety of measures
that we're gonna try to get a consensus
you know four years from now that in
these five sites if teachers can say hey
I like this it got rid of the right
people it helped the rest of us here do
better it was not capricious it was not
high overhead you know I really like
this if that can happen in the five
sites and they can tell everybody else
that would be good if you say what's the
riskiest thing the foundation is doing
it's that teacher personnel activity
because the status quo is immensely
powerful there when we invent vaccines
no group I won't name who it is
can uninvent the vaccine if you do good
education there are groups that can send
you back to to square zero and that that
has happened in in many cases hello my
name is Matt Denman and I'm a PhD in
nuclear engineering and I was wondering
you mentioned the importance of low
carbon energy to the world's future can
you take a couple minutes to talk about
the role of nuclear power to provide
that energy given that you're investing
in nuclear reactor designs it through
tear up our well energy problems one of
these incredible problems and the
Prioress of civilization you can almost
measure it as as the price of energy
goes down so many great things happen
and we have a civilization that's based
on very cheap power and you know it's
great we need to continue that if you
look at what technologies could really
provide the electricity demand say 40
years from now there are very few and
most the ones that are kind of cute and
cuddly have to
big problems I'm talking about solar PV
solar thermal solar chemical the very
solar approaches or the wind approach
they those two have one its energy
farming and so the density you know the
acreage involved you know the watts per
square meter of those things you know it
makes it very hard and when you do
farming you get wind you get snow you
get you know your capital equipment
isn't in a cold plant that's protected
from the elements it's it's large
widespread so that's very hard but even
if you get passed out there's the
intermittency problem where you can't on
a 24-hour period or you know when the
clouds screw you up or the wind doesn't
blow you have this storage problem and
you can ask I think reasonable
researchers will there be in the next 40
years the ability to store say the
amount of energy that the u.s. uses of
our 24-hour period in pick your favorite
technique battery water storage
you know thermal storage there aren't
many many choices and it's not clear we
should work on that you know professor
Sadoway a lot of people are looking at
radical battery technology that could in
terms of cost and capacity get us in a
very different space than even the
lifting and learning curve will get us
to so you don't want to just bet on
those because their costs are hard
because it's farming and the
intermittency thing once you get above
say 20 percent from intermittent sources
you've got a problem it's cute it works
well up to about 20 percent we asked the
base load guys which today those are the
hydro coal natural gas nuclear guys you
ask them to suck it up when the wind
wind doesn't blow anyway nuclear in some
ways is the coolest of all because it
you put the plant near the demand you
don't care if they're Sun or not there's
lots of countries that don't have Sun
and wind much at all and so you have to
say are they willing to have the
political risk of having their energy
coming from say Libya and you know over
some big
transmission infrastructure anyway
nuclear has the advantage that the
amount of energy sort of per atom is
about a million times better than you
know coal or natural gas you start with
this huge advantage and yet given the
complexity of the plants and the things
you have to do you more than wipe out
your million for one advantage and
today's nuclear plants are fairly
expensive at least the way they're built
outside of China they're quite expensive
China is actually building them in three
years and competitive with coal so
they're they're pushing the
state-of-the-art and they're
standardizing designs and things like
that anyway so nuclear is one of the
directions that we should innovate and
nuclear innovation stopped in the 1970s
we basically have this sub design thing
that was put into shipping port for the
first powered generator and you know we
basically built 400 of those that are
you know all kind of custom but not in
any interesting way they're all LWR some
PWRs
and the industry did not innovate much
at all there's this third generation
passive safety ap1000 but except for
that it didn't do much the question is
can we get you know a thousand bright
minds with twenty different ideas and
we're starting to see that you know I
don't happen to believe in modular
reactors but some people do that's great
you know some people like these molten
salt reactors that's a little bit tricky
the crazy group I'm backing we use u-238
depleted uranium and because we have
fast neutrons we have this Neutron
budget that's very different now our
main problem is a material science
problem is these damn neutrons degrade
the cladding and everything and we don't
have a predictable way of saying you
know over a 40-year lifetime how various
materials deal with that if you look at
the fusion guys their neutrons are like
a thousand times worse than our neutrons
but even ours or are they those guys
have 14 MeV neutrons good luck to them
but you know some people should work on
that it's not that is not an easy thing
in terms of the economics so nuclear in
terms of basement
and is incredible and if you use this
approach we're talking about it is
infinite that is you can filter out of
the sea very cheaply enough uranium to
run this thing for as long as the Sun
will shine so in that sense you know is
it renewable quote well it's infinite
you don't worry about the amount of
uranium so anyway I think it's one of
the approaches that ton more should be
done in we need more money in material
science we need more hunting batteries
we need more money in transmission this
is an under investment area where you
know the government actually does raise
trading money or carbon tax money some
of the bills have been proposed don't
actually fund R&D at a reasonable level
so it's a it's kind of a tragic thing
that hopefully if we get a revenue
source that we can take the energy R&D
and get it up you know maybe a factor of
three or four more there's a few good
things going on like DARPA II but that
doesn't work for nuclear but I love I
love nuclear it does this radiation
thing is tricky but there are good good
solutions you know it was interesting
recently in Connecticut ice natural gas
plant blew up 11 guys it just blew him
up actually I think killed 506 if that
had been a nuclear plant
you know everybody would know about that
you know coal mines yeah China did a
good job last year they went from 33
hundred guys dying in coal mining
accidents to 2,600 very impressive don't
you think
but if nuclear had killed those 2,600
people I mean we would just be you know
kiss the whole industry goodbye it's
interesting you know deaths per megawatt
nuclear is the the the minimizer
[Music]
these things but it's got a lot of
challenges but you know it's great I'm
glad it there's this Renaissance of
people going in Tunica we have this
company and everybody in the company is
either over 60 because they have done
something or they're in their 20s or 30s
because they're open-minded and
optimistic so it's an interesting
bimodal we don't have anybody in their
40s and 50s because that was the nuclear
shutdown period is when those people
would have would have been trained go
ahead
hi my name is Ron Jeff I'm a freshman
and I'm researching with Professor
Sadoway actually and thank you for
coming to MIT though you probably like
Harvard better so my question is
two-part the first part is that earlier
you were talking about how you think
that it'll be a challenge to get a lot
of young people into researching for
helping poverty and helping the world
issues because they might not find a
financial incentive in this and you said
that this would be an interesting
problem to look at but I was wondering
first of all if you could elaborate a
little bit on how you would look at this
problem and what sorts of approaches you
would take and you want me to say the
second part now or after the you know
part of the solution is to take
corporations like drug companies phone
companies banks and get them to put some
of their innovators on these problems
that are less remunerate 'iv perhaps but
you know overall in terms of their
reputation and hiring and things like
that and that's happening we funded a
group called access to medicines that
ranks the pharmaceutical companies
according to how much they work on
diseases of the poor and it came out
like we thought it would with GSK on top
and various other people in the bottom
and the right thing happened which is
the people on the bottom called us up
and said this is embarrassing well you
know are there projects and things we
should be doing
and so spreading that to other
industries banking cell phones the food
companies been great we haven't done the
index yet but the Nestle's Unilever's
cokes their willingness to work with us
on agricultural sourcing nutrition
products they've been amazingly
effective so bringing the companies in
so that you have people are working at
the companies who can do this that's
important government funding for these
things which is mostly the delivery
piece that's in the foreign aid budget
making the case for that that that
should say strong it's very important
getting people like the NIH who are
others but NIH is big to tilt a little
bit towards the disease of the porn
terms the work they do and Francis
Collins the current director is thinking
about some creative things there that'll
happen ironically drug approval is still
this weird thing where poor countries
don't trust themselves to approve drugs
and so when we want to do a new TB drug
it has to be approved it won't no
country will accept it and last either
FDA the u.s. regulator or Mia that the
European regulator accepts it and they
don't have the right process for triple
drug therapy they'd make us under normal
things go through three phase threes
which that's 15 years and over a billion
dollars so they're working with us on
these things you know we're trying to
get vouchers where if you do drugs for
the poor you get faster FDA review on
your richworld drugs so you know we need
government philanthropy and corporate
money to go into this and that's the
economic piece then we need the
visibility where people feel like this
is a great thing and that you know there
is progress but whether it's prizes or
awards or things like that there's a lot
more that can be done so what's the
second the second is less academic I'm
just curious how does being the richest
person in the world affect your life I
mean
well they it the marginal return for
extra dollars does drop off you know you
know I haven't found any burgers at any
price that are better than McDonald's
[Music]
there's a few things like air travel
where it's nice but you know other than
that overwhelmingly once you get past
you know some point I don't know what it
is a few million or something then it's
all about how you're going to give it
back
you know what what are you gonna pick
someone or you're gonna get involved
yourself how are you going to do that
and you know for some people strangely
that's actually a burden where they're
you know kind of weird they want to do
it well or all out and so put you know
partly making that easier making that
more widespread is one of the things I
think is interesting that can help more
you know if we could double philanthropy
if we can get Indian China billionaires
for example to be as generous as the
u.s. is or get the u.s. be twice as
generous and then get them to match up
to that it'd be a substantial amount of
money well I guess I've used up all my
time so that you know thank you those
were great questions let me just leave
you with a small challenge or
opportunity which is that on the
foundation Facebook website if you have
ideas about a particular problem or the
general issue of drawing people in if
you have ideas about that I encourage
you to post there because I'll you know
go look at that and see if there's
things that we ought to help promote and
hopefully we'll get you know a lot of
good ideas you know I you know obviously
coming here you're you're people who
believe in these things so I I want to
thank you for that but you know think
hard about how we can get even even more
people involved
okay so Thank You mr. gates for taking
the time to answer our questions please
accept on behalf of my fellow students
our appreciation for your interest in
our work and I speak for everyone here
in thanking you for the support and
friendship you've shown to MIT
[Applause]